This brings us to a very important consequence of stereotypes, and that's
called stereotype threat. Which are situations in which people are aware they
belong to the minority, and this awareness negatively affects their performance
on a task. Let's look at this example of a research study done by Steele and
Aronson. The researchers have African-American and Caucasian students take a
test. Half of the students were asked to write their race at the top of the
test. Afterwards, they analyzed the results. Do you think they found a
difference between the group who wrote their race at the beginning of the test
as compared to those who did not? Yes or no? If you say yes, why? And if you
say no, why?